all right
okay folks like i'd like to get started
with this is
we're having a
full committee work session on interim
study bills we are
not going to
[Music]
dispose of any bill
today
this is uh this is our start to be able
to see where we want to go as a
committee with the with these bills
we'll we'll be
dividing up things if we have a any
uh bills any uh
what we will do with each each of these
bills some bills we will
lump into uh
one one subcommittee others will be by
themselves
uh and others will not have any sub
committee they will just go to the uh
a
so an executive session
in september or october
uh with that first uh
i'd like
yes
representative howard please leave this
in the pledge yes please join me in a
pledge to old glory i pledge allegiance
to the flag of the united states of
america and to the republic for which it
stands one nation under god invisible
with liberty and justice for all
as we'll get right into the
business
uh
mr dears
eric
chair recognizes miss
mr dears to give us
give the
to
give us some
background in the tutorial some
education around
uh
well before 26 and 257 were relative
to
the
uh
pollutants from uh
septic systems uh there are two bills
that
that that
deal with this subject
and i uh we asked mr dears to
give us a uh give bring us all up to
speed
as to the
what what the science is and what the
need is and things of that nature
mr dears
the floor is yours
thank you mr chair thank you members of
the committee it's great to be with you
again i think everyone's looking
refreshed after a little bit of time
between the session uh so i hope you're
all having a great summer um i am very
pleased to talk to you a little bit
today um about sort of the um
i'm gonna call it the great bass saga uh
because it's been going on for so long
and because many of you
are relatively new on the committee um
it may be that you haven't heard uh the
saga i'm not gonna do it as an ode or
anything like that or in you know a song
uh as as perhaps we probably should at
this point but i'm gonna just tell you a
little bit about the history of sort of
how we got here
and the reason for that is to talk a
little bit about why uh senate bill 257
is a thing
and so i know senator waters is uh is a
sponsor of that and he is behind me here
and i'm sure that he can also wax
eloquent about the reasons for this bill
but i'm going to give it just a quick
shot as to kind of how we got here so
back in the early 2000s
we started doing the state of the
estuary reports and this came from the
piscataqua region estuaries partnership
and one of the things that happened as
doing those is there a bunch of
indicators
indicators of estuary health
so
just to define my terms an estuary is
simply a place where freshwater meets
saltwater and the great bay is our
largest of estuaries and it's pretty a
significant resource nationally as well
as regional
so the great bay was starting to show
signs of stress through these indicators
and one of the primary ones was the loss
of eelgrass so eelgrass is a submerged
aquatic vegetation zastromuridima for
those of you who like the latin names uh
it's quite fun to say not as fun as a
muffle of breville gilada which is beach
grass but almost as fun um and so
so eelgrass is a fundamental basis of
the ecosystem of the estuary it's where
the fish hang out it's where fish have
nurseries there's flounder have their
babies in there we have
there's shellfish it cleans the water so
as it waves it's very long and wavy and
as it waves its its leaves and and stems
in the water it captures sediment it
takes up nutrients
and so that was declining precipitously
in great bail by between 1996 and around
2000 2004 about half of the eelgrass in
great bay was gone
and so they started looking at this and
one of the things that also came up at
the same time looking at all these
different indicators is that nutrients
nitrogen in particular have increased
dramatically over time
and one of the things we know from the
research around the world is that
nitrogen
too much nitrogen and estuary tends to
impact the eel eelgrass
which has lots of different than it's
it's basically a a a positive
reinforcement um it's a a positive
feedback loop positive meaning that that
one thing causes the other leaves of the
other lays the other
and so when you start to lose the when
you start to get too much nutrients you
start to have less light
when you have less light the eelgrass
don't get as much light
and then the eelgrass start to die
which then causes you to not trap as
much sediments then you have less light
which causes more eelgrass to die which
causes the estuary to sort of go into
this downward spiral
so we had good indications at the time
that this was going on
as a result of that we launched a fairly
monumental effort to develop
ideas about how much nutrients would
have to be reduced in order to
in order to get the estuary to be
healthy again
as a result of that we started to see
numbers coming out and understanding a
little bit more about what would need to
be reduced and from where it was coming
there's a chart a color chart in the
middle of your
uh of your packet there that looks a
little bit like
um pac-man uh eating one of those fun
dots that pac-man eat
and
that um
that colored chart there shows you sort
of where does all this nitrogen come
from
so
only about about a third or so comes
from wastewater treatment plants so each
of us every every year each of us
creates about seven pounds of nitrogen
uh through our bodily functions
that nitrogen all goes to wastewater
treatment plants or your septic system
or you know hopefully those are the two
places it goes and um
that
that then has to get treated and that
nitrogen is generally because of the way
that our wastewater treatment plants
were created they were not meant to
treat for nitrogen
so the nitrogen pretty much went through
the plants and into the estuary and
that's what was one of the sources
the rest of the 75 or so or 70 percent
comes from other things comes from
atmospheric deposition we get a lot of
nitrogen that comes from uh the midwest
through power plants uh you've heard of
when we talk about acid rain you've
heard of nox and socks um you know
nitric
oxides and sulfur oxides you know those
are not just dr seuss terms nox and
socks they are these pollutants and
nitrogen uh precipitates falls onto the
ground and that washes off into off of
pavement and into our estuaries most of
it is taken up in forests this is one of
the reasons why it's great that we have
so many forests
takes up that nitrogen
so that nitrogen has to go somewhere
also nitrogen comes from fertilizers not
as much here in terms of agriculture but
certainly uh one of the studies we did
showed that we have about 45 000 acres
of lawn in the great bay watershed
much of which gets fertilizer much of
which has nitrogen in it so all of this
combines and so
by the time we got to the sort of 2010s
it was very clear that there needed to
be reductions
so epa who writes our permits here for
new hampshire began looking at what
would we have to do
and one of the problems with this whole
thing is that epa really only has its
hooks
into the wastewater treatment plants
it doesn't have its hooks into those
other sources that i suggested
so what the so what epa because that's
their one hook they began proposing to
do draconian reductions at our
wastewater treatment plants
reductions that would be extraordinarily
expensive to meet
and so as a result of that
the state and the communities uh became
lots and lots and lots and lots of
discussions over the ensuing 10 years or
so
epa agreed to take a completely novel
approach
this is novel for the nation no one else
has done this in this way and what they
did was they created this great bay
nitrogen general permit
so what they did was they took the
nitrogen part out of the whole permit
system that normally wastewater
treatment plants are permitted under and
created this general permit that applies
to the 13 wastewater treatment plants
and their communities around the great
bay
and what that innovative approach did
was it set an end of the pipe limit but
the end of the pipe is the end of the
piscataqua river so it basically looks
at the whole watershed looks at how much
nitrogen is coming down on the whole
watershed and then attempts to regulate
that based on the whole thing instead of
each sort of facility
so then they back that up into each sort
of what each facility was contributing
and then allowed them to lock in the
good work and the investments that
they'd been making over the last 10
years and just be clear the communities
around great b great bay have dug in you
know that portsmouth spent 94 million
dollars on a new wastewater treatment
plant at pierce island that has
excellent nitrogen treatment exeter
small exeter spent 54 million dollars
rochester has taken their nitrogen from
40 micrograms per liter down to four
micrograms per liter
this is amazing they've done amazing
work huge investments that have gone on
but it's not quite enough in order
because they're only 30 of the problem
so the idea with this great bayonet
great bay nitrogen general permit was to
be able to build in a system of
trade-offs that system of trade-off
trade-offs does not exist within the
clean water act
so this is a new tool that was developed
for this purpose it is voluntary
the communities have can voluntarily go
into this
and if they voluntarily go into this
then they they have to do a few things
they have to contribute to monitoring so
how what's actually going on in the
estuary they have to track the nitrogen
that they're emitting from their
communities so we built a system des
funded it to build a system that tracks
their pollutants so any subdivision that
goes in or a redevelopment project
that's you know that's putting in new
best management practices all of that is
tracked within this this um this this
database in fact newmarket has done
phenomenally uh and we've tracked those
reductions uh that they've made from for
in in this case they hooked their
elementary school
instead of all the wastewater going into
the into the to right to the estuary
they put in infiltration basins they did
some other things which disconnected all
of that impervious remember all the
nitrogen that's falling from the sky and
landing on the on that pavement
so the communities have to track what
they're doing they also develop a
nitrogen reduction plan that addresses
those other sources other than their
wastewater treatment plant
so they're looking at all of those other
sources so
dover right now when they put in a new
road
when they dig up the side they don't
just put it back with the same
storm drain basins they've actually
invented their own sort of water
treatment system that goes in front of
the uh the storm drains that actually
causes the nitrogen to essentially
filter out as it goes through
as well as other pollutants
it's not just about nitrogen when you
start talking about storm water it's
about flooding it's about it's about
other night other you know phosphorus
it's about other pollutants bacteria
that would be in the water so it's a
win-win-win when you do that because not
only are you improving your your your
aged infrastructure
but you're reducing flooding and you get
that pollution benefit as well at the
same time this is why this trade-off is
so important
but this is also this is where we get to
this requires you to use a silver
buckshot approach
right there's no silver bullet it's a
silver buckshot approach
so what you need to do is find all of
the places that you can possibly reduce
nitrogen
i mentioned that each of us creates
about seven pounds of nitrogen a year
if you're on a septic system your septic
system does a remarkable job
at pulling out all kinds of things out
of the water it pulls out phosphorus it
treats the bacteria it it even is pretty
good at doing things like
pharmaceuticals and personal care
products
lots of those things get get caught up
and treated very nicely in your septic
system
nitrogen goes into solution
and septic systems are extremely good at
taking things that are in solution and
putting them into the ground that's what
they're built to do
so septic systems the straight up
well-functioning modern septic system is
extremely good at putting nitrogen
directly into the groundwater
so when we start talking about can you
address this so for example in dover
they have a certain population outside
of the the main downtown area that is on
septic systems
so as they start to think about again a
silver buckshot approach how would they
start to address putting in expensive
upgrades to those systems
without requiring the those those people
who owned them to spend that kind of
money
that's where this idea about a septic
utility comes from
how would the community so the community
dover could
come to the srf program at des
get some loan forgiveness
as part of that put that into their
normal operating budget as the community
and then create basically a utility
around that that would put in a an
upgraded system that would treat for
nitrogen
it would do the maintenance on that
system every year make sure that it's
it's working
the people attached to it would pay
would probably pay a fee like you'd pay
a sewer fee
but you would no longer have to be
responsible for pumping it out you'd no
longer be responsible for replacing it
if it broke
someone else would do that
so if they went down that road and it
would take the vote of the the city
council and input from all the you know
people in town as as part of the public
process
if they decided to do that then they
would get credits remember i said we
built this system where they can track
their nitrogen
this would be one of the things that
they would be able to track
and at the end of this permit what
they're required to show is that they
did what they could to reduce nitrogen
and see what's going on in the estuary
and we we hope and we think that when we
get to the end of that we're going to
see major improvements in the ecology of
great bay
that's where this bill comes out of it's
out of that desire
i think this is going to be very very
rare that this gets employed i've also
talked to some folks around some lake
communities
that have say a small neighborhood
that all you know was all put in at the
same time
maybe the developer wasn't so reputable
the septic systems are all failing and
that may be another place where that
community wants to get together maybe
even a neighborhood sort of association
build a stormwater utility which the you
know the law would allow that to happen
and be able to then access funding
because currently an individual
homeowner unless you're very poor there
are very few avenues to access funding
for septic system replacement this would
be a place in which that that new
district that utility
could go after srf funds they could get
grants they could do other things that
would allow them to spread those
payments out and allow people to replace
their systems without having to you know
you know pay a huge amount up front
which is very challenging for people to
do
so that's really the essence of 257 and
you know i i just wanted to i'll stop
there and see if people have questions i
gave you some materials to just kind of
show
you know what do we know about eelgrass
uh there's a little chart there on the
front what do we know about total
nitrogen that's from the chico river and
you can see that since rochester and
dover um have been doing so much better
especially rochester here in the kachico
since they've been doing so much better
at reducing the nitrogen you see the
nitrogen reductions in the river
so we're tracking what's going on there
the second page i put in just a couple
of little factoids about what a storm
water utility is kind of why those exist
for those of you who are involved in
concord the concord is looking at a
storm water utility
the primary reason there is that
something like 40 of the pavement in
this city is either owned is is
untaxable by the city
so
that means that all of the runoff is
paid for by the by the good people of
concord
in their taxes
whereas to treat that storm water in a
utility everyone would pay
a little bit and it would you know be
able to to raise more dollars to deal
with the serious problems that exist
with aging infrastructure as well as
spread that across the
people who are currently untaxed
um and i sort of talked a little bit
about the septic utility and then you
know one of the other things that's come
up is septic impacts on lakes
and i can certainly talk more about that
in the context of
hb426
but you know we are definitely in a
situation in which cyanobacteria blooms
are getting worse and worse this year
the first time we had two water supply
lakes
that had cyanobacteria blooms
so this is very scary stuff because of
the toxins involved in the cyanobacteria
so um you know i think this is another
place in which there needs to be some
some thought addressing uh potential
pollution sources into our our lakes
so
i'm going to stop there and see if
thank you mr dears for an excellent
presentation
i wanted to
just get some clarification on the
home septic systems sure you said if
this
if a community were to
[Music]
uh take advantage of this enabling
legislation if this bill were to become
law
or something similar you said um
in lake communities where septic systems
are failing
this could help the homeowner whose
system was failing
say for instance if it was
installed poorly
um
some remediation financial remediation
and then you i thought you said that
they wouldn't be having to pump their
tanks themselves anymore
so could you clarify how this would work
yeah again i think this is going to be
super rare that this happens but it will
happen on occasion i can picture
i can picture any number of
neighborhoods around lakes they were all
kind of put in at the same time and
their all their septic systems are
failing at the same time
it's pretty common
and so one of the things that could
happen is say that group that homeowner
group decides that they want to build a
district
basically a utility
and when you do that because these
systems again if you're going to go with
some advanced systems or something like
that
you could have the utility handle all of
the maintenance on that and in fact you
would want to do that to protect your
your investment it would be similar to
us to a wastewater system that now um
you know they they treat the pipes all
the way to your house
they do other things this would be sort
of that next step where they would
actually you know depending on how the
utility is set up they would most likely
do the maintenance on that so you'd pay
a fee into it every year and that would
pay the the amortization of you know the
cost of the putting all these systems in
as well as it would fund the maintenance
over time
that's assist that's a place in which
that would definitely need all of the
homeowners to agree that that's what
they want to do
this is why i think it's going to be
really rare
um but i think it's going to be really
helpful in certain circumstances in
which there are a few other options
sewering is not an option for example um
there are parts of lake winnipesaukee
that you know the winosaki basin project
didn't go all the way around the lake so
there's whole areas that don't have and
there's some tight neighborhoods in
there that could potentially do this
sort of thing
um and then of course i think great bay
was the focus that was the original way
that this bill was written was for those
great bay communities and that's kind of
the description i think which is
probably more likely in the short run
would be you know as part of a larger
effort a larger system that would you
know be pulling some of those in
thanks
[Music]
for a question representative here we go
thank you mr chair
um so this uh
this system that's being put in
um is it like a mini wastewater
treatment plant
what is it so thank you for the question
representative spang um
what they have is a number of different
kinds of systems and the whole the way
that you get nitrogen out of water
is that you have to alternate back and
forth between
an anaerobic environment and an aerobic
environment your septic system is only
anaerobic there's not much oxygen down
in there
so what happens is essentially it would
go into some sort of a
mechanical system
be small you know because it's part of
you just part of your septic system but
it would have some way of introducing
oxygen back into the system at some
point in the process
some of them are more elaborate than
others so some of them would have ways
of recirculating some of the waste back
in through the system because the more
you can because what happens is that as
you put air in then there's bacteria
natural bacteria that take the nitrogen
and deny and denitrify it which means
that they send it up into the oxygen our
oxygen as you all know is mostly
nitrogen our our atmosphere is mostly
oxide is mostly nitrogen not oxygen
anyway um so it sends it up into the
atmosphere
in order what happens then is as those
little bugs are chewing up the nitrogen
they chew up all the carbon because
that's their fuel and so you have
sometimes you have to have a way of
putting more carbon back in which is
coming back out of your waste that's how
a waste or treatment plant works but
this is really it's it would look mostly
like a septic system but might have a
little mechanical structure that would
sit you know as part some at some point
in the process that's how some of these
work there's other ones that are now
being laid out that are more passive
where they put a layer of wood chips or
other kinds of carbon media underneath
your leech field and that has the effect
of again being able to have some of that
carbon to be able to take up
for the question further question thank
you so
i had envisioned all of these houses
being hooked up to a central
plant but it's actually occurring on
each septic system
on the shoreland
commission that i chaired
we talked a lot about innovative systems
particularly for areas that were very
close to the shore and where you really
couldn't put in a decent septic system
how does that relate to this utility
it's very similar um the the the
treatments
the treatment protocols for phosphorus
are different than they are for nitrogen
so around a lake you're talking about it
but it's a similar kind of system
you know it'd be similar sort of sort of
approach where you have
some sort of system and most likely it
includes some sort of mechanical
parts this is why the maintenance
becomes so critical this is why a
utility becomes critical is that you
basically have to have a some sort of
third party maintenance to keep this to
keep them going and the homeowner is you
know because they're they move
most people a lot of people buy a house
they don't even know where the septic
system is
they don't even know that they have a
so often so you know it that's why this
kind of thing becomes necessary is to
have that kind of centralized
infrastructure to be able to deal with
that so that that's kind of where it
works one more clarification thank you
so the um
would this utility pay for a landowner
a property owner to upgrade from a
standard system
to one of these innovative systems
that's generally what would be involved
especially like take the great bay
example
take the dover example so they would
identify say an area of the town that
would have the highest potential for
reduction of nitrogen because remember
the towns are going this is a value
engineering proposition okay they're
doing whatever is the least
cost next pound of nitrogen removal
so that's the that's the whole premise
here it's not that they're targeting one
thing or another because it because of
of some reason it's because they're char
they're targeting the next pound of
cheapest nitrogen it's pure economics
and so if the next pound of cheapest
nitrogen to get out
is through some set of septic systems
and the cost of that given the whole
replacement of the system
you know the maintenance of the system
doing all of that makes sense
then and then there's grants and there's
and there's there's loans to be able to
do that
that may be the cheapest next pound and
so that's where this would come into
play it wouldn't be willy-nilly it would
be as a result of that kind of analysis
i have a question yes sir
yeah being being kind of slow i need to
uh does this mean
that
we can forget about
uh leech fields from now on
so
thank you for the question mr chair
the answer is no
for for the vast majority of people
anywhere you you are in the state who
has a septic system
that system is
perfectly adequate
and even if you had an advanced system
almost always you would also have a
leech field of some sort so you still
have to get the water back into the
ground somewhere you're still not you
can't make the water disappear
so it's highly unlikely that you would
have the system that would go into the
little treatment hut we'll call it a
treatment hut the treatment cabana that
would be in your backyard and then that
water would then flow directly into a
lake that would never happen you would
still be nest needing to put that water
back into the ground and the best way to
put that back into the ground is through
a leech field because it spreads it out
and it has a media underneath it that
continues to even give it more treatment
for those of you who haven't seen a
septic system get dug up
i recommend you see it at some point
because the the the engine of treatment
that treat the thing that treats all the
bacteria and all the other nasties that
are coming coming out of the house
is this almost microscopic thin layer of
biological film that occurs on the
outside of the stones at the bottom of
your leech field
it's
truly magical how this system works i
know i get excited about substances but
it's not just a hole in the ground in
which one pours water
these are highly engineered well thought
out and they're biological engines that
are that are that are truly a miracle of
any other questions by
members of the committee
representatives
actually mr chair um
are we also going to discuss the other
bill um 426 or is this a combined
discussion
uh
yes thank you mr chairs i'd like to
thank you also for pointing out the work
that rochester's done my hometown
and uh because i know over the years
that i served on the city council we did
a lot of work on getting our water
quality and wastewater treatment plant
to be one of the best in the state of
new hampshire and it's great to be
pointed but it's also at the beginning
it's been millions of dollars to the
ratepayers in the in the community
and it's also interesting because i've
done a lot of research in looking at
sequencing back batch reactors if for
small uses
and uh because i know it's something
that's been significantly done in
western massachusetts for
residential communities or downtown
areas that they don't have the septic
systems available to them
and there's a lot of innovative stuff
out here do you see these bills as being
a way to encourage more of that to occur
in the state of new hampshire
thank you for the question uh
representative um and um
and rochester's fantastic they're doing
they really are doing innovative stuff
in rochester
the um
yeah i don't know i guess that's the
answer is that that there's a lot of
people looking at decentralized systems
in lots of new ways
um for for a lot of reasons cost
you know the amount of treatment that
has to happen
um
and so
you know the cost of a new wastewater
treatment plant
is
you know for you know a million gallons
a day is is on the order of 25 million
dollars
and there's a lot of communities that
just aren't going to have that kind of
money so
you know this is
these there are a lot of new treatment
uh technologies that are being developed
um worldwide uh to deal with the the
issue of human waste so
you know potentially so you could say
like if you had a number of of
decentralized villages say for example
and each of them
you know wanted to do some sort of a
system you could again develop some sort
of a utility that would deal with that
um so i don't know i mean that i think
that that's sort of you know speculative
at this point i don't think we're there
yet but with the housing issue that we
have here in the state there's a lot of
areas that could sustain additional
housing and high density higher density
housing if there was a way to treat the
wastewater because that seems to be when
you take a look at the calculations for
minimum lot size for housing units
and the number of bedrooms you have on a
site sometimes it becomes prohibitively
expensive to be able to to make a
compact compact housing
and to be able to do these you know i
just want to i know that batch reactors
have been out there for years i've been
looking at them for over 20 years and
having those
to be able to support
increased density and housing in some
areas which would normally not be able
to switch would it you know would it be
affordable
as i said a lot of places in western
massachusetts have done them uh to
support that and and in some very
innovative ways at a far reduced cost to
spending 25 million dollars to build a
sewage treatment plant
so it's something that we possibly
should be looking at
in the short term in order to try to
bring these technologies to the state or
new hampshire and using more of them
yeah you know i think that community
systems are incredibly important you see
this a lot at um you know at uh co-op
communities
where in a spa and this is one of the
problems that we have right now one of
the reasons why des is allocating a
significant amount of both arpa and
infrastructure money towards
disenfranchised communities is towards
the co-ops that oftentimes when they
bought up the co-op
the the systems that were there had not
been maintained and so they're
installing community systems and i
certainly think that there's an
opportunity in the future for either
having you know sort of a utility
approach to their community systems
either multiple systems or being able to
have some innovative approaches to being
able to deal with that but that's you
know i think that's really that's in my
mind that's where the first place
where you're going to see that kind of
approach is is out of necessity in some
of these especially you know places that
just when they bought when they bought
up their their their co-op
you know it was at the outside edge of
what people could afford and then you
have a water and sewer problem on top of
that and that's what really becomes a
problem uh for folks and we've seen that
around the state
for a question
thank you mr chairman um the
i'm going to raise some of the issues of
some of my colleagues in terms of the
cost to the private property owner
i i think a lot of us myself included
thought that this was going to be
something that was going to be say
citywide
so the the council would be approving it
um
you you would be dragged in by the
majority whether whether or not you
but you're saying that that's not the
way it will work
is there any fear that the private
resident would be in some terms forced
to do this
and what would be the cost comparison
between
they're paying into this utility and
they're paying to maintain their own
system possibly replacing it so thank
you for the question and i think that
this is really why i think the committee
would benefit from hearing from some
additional expertise
on this issue
of how utilities work and how they would
be costed out and how they would be
looking at that
because i think that there are ways to
address that in in in hb 256
77 did i get
lost it out of my head for a second um
that i think that there may be ways and
i think senator waters probably has
great ideas on how to do that already uh
i'm sure he does um but
i think that this is why maybe a
subcommittee might want to look at this
is it's really i think that's the the
crux of people need to understand
what would be the implications and and
how would the individual homeowner know
what those implications are
i think that we heard that as a valid
concern as this went through the the
testimony process earlier this session
and i think it's something that we could
probably benefit from some additional
expertise coming in and chatting with
you about okay
follow-up
um
so i think um
even though it's done
little micro community by micro
community and the people in say that
subdivision
would hopefully unanimously decide that
they want to do it
nevertheless it's a municipality the
city council
that needs to enact the legislation that
we're offering them
in order to the for those little micro
communities to do this
and to access all of the state money
in order to do that have i got that
right yeah they would have it would have
i mean
in the course of a city it would
certainly have to go through their city
council
um you can't just you know start doing
stuff
without that kind of because it would
have money involved it would have
expenditure involved so all of that
would have to go through you know the
public process through their city
council
a wee follow-up so would that be that
project by project would have to be
approved by the city council or the city
council would just say
now we're unable to do this and anywhere
that
at any of these little subcommittees
want to do it you now have the ability
yeah i don't know the answer to that i
think it would totally depend on how you
set up the utility right this was this
is why i think you know each one of
these is going to be different and it's
going to be different just the way that
every you know utility in the state is
slightly different um they do slightly
different things in different ways they
have different fee schedules they you
know they do a lot of and it's because
of
the particulars of that situation so i i
think that you know and again i think it
would be good to bring in some city
officials to ask them that question you
know what would have to happen in order
for this to move forward if it were if
if authorizing legislation were passed
you know how would you go about doing
this
okay thank you
representative smith
thank you mr chair and thank you again
um mr dears um when i'm looking at i'm
talking about now house bill 426
and i think you know i can't imagine
there's anyone who
doesn't want to prevent the flow of
nitrogen or the results of a failed
septic system into any of our lakes or
rivers
but if i'm looking at the statute as it
stands now
um
it says if a septic and this is has to
do with the uh assessment study the site
assessment study right i mean someone
gave me this handout i don't know if it
was you or if representative spang
um if
in
section roman 8 if the septic
disposed system designer during the
course of the site assessment discovers
evidence that there is sewage discharge
on the ground surface or directly into
surface waters the designer shall notify
in writing the department and the health
officer and shall include information in
the site assessment report
and then in the letter that des sent us
in testimony last year
it
it suggested changing this to if the
septic system is in failure
and i wondered what the definition of
failure is and if that needs to be
tweaked i'm trying to figure out how we
can get to yes on this bill
not necessarily this bill but the
concept to better protect the water from
failed septic systems
yeah this is uh thank you for the
question and um i unfortunately i'm i'm
getting up to speed on septic
rules and such um in my new position
but but rob tardif who was our expert
retired at the end of may so so but i
will i certainly have looked at this a
little bit and i will speak to it as
there is
been a controversy in the whole way in
which septic systems have been
looked at
between
and these are these these are not just
semantics between the word
um evaluation
and and um
and about evaluation and assessment so
those are two really different things
and who does the evaluation or the
assessment is also important because
there are different levels of
qualification
so
for example and uh there are people who
can simply do the wet sneaker test
that's what we call the wet sneaker test
if you go out and you're sloshing around
on top of the septic system
it's in failure right i mean that's
that's clearly not working correctly
right
the pure definition of failure
in our in our statutes
is that it does not meet the
requirements of separation between the
system and the groundwater table
so purely speaking that's the definition
of a failure and it's very easy to
figure that out
you have you you auger a hole you find
out how deep the water table is
you know how deep the septic system is
because you had a design
and you can compare the two
so it's very simple to do that but it's
not the wet sneaker test and so this is
really the crux of this whole
the whole that part of the bill
is really about
what is that what is it that will
protect buyers and sellers right
you know what is it that protects the
the seller from someone coming back at
them saying you sold me a failed system
or the the buyer from buying something
that says
yeah i just bought i just bought a pig
and a pope
right so so
that's the crux of this bill and i think
that this bill can be improved
and i think we heard testimony from
various different people that suggested
that there may be ways of improving it
um you know and i think from the the
septic system
commission that was
last year was just last year okay i was
thinking of other commissions um
that
madam chair has chaired
the um
that uh
you know there there are a number of
different recommendations within this
and these were a couple of the common
sense ones and so i think that you know
those are
things that could be addressed um to to
better to improve this bill if the
committee so desired
and i think we've thought about this and
i mentioned this just in my little
tidbits here i think we have some
thoughts at des again about you know
let's let's focus this on the things
thank you this is you've been
uh remember this is going to a
subcommittee committee
right
but the committee the committee is going
to be voting on whether to send it to
subcommittee or not right no
that's my job oh that's your job well
i'll just turn this off
just to follow up um for everybody's
uh edification
the commission
himself got kind of tangled up for a
while
it looks to me like it's possible for a
property to pass the assessment
because the assessment is just somebody
looking at a map
and looking at the wetlands and saying
yeah this
this site is capable of holding a septic
system
of with the number of bedrooms that are
being proposed
but it doesn't say anything about
whether the septic system is that's in
there
is functioning properly so it'd be
possible to get a good assessment
and have
a failing system
bro if you did an evaluation of the
system itself yeah this is where i think
that the committee would uh would would
benefit from some additional testimony
hearing from people who actually do this
for a living and understanding the the
nuances
again these are sort of magical things
that sit in our backyards um and so
understanding a little bit more about
you know
how do we really understand the the
health of those and that they're doing
the right thing and that that a buyer is
buying what they think they are and a
seller is selling what they think they
are you know this this is uh it's an
important aspect and so i again i think
that that's why you know hearing some
additional testimony from folks
who who are out there um
you know digging you know digging in the
dirt uh would be helpful great thank you
uh
i know there's a lot more questions i
know i have a lot more questions but
i'll save those for the
subcommittee
uh
but is there any other
issues any anything else that
is of concern relative to this so do you
have additional comments you want to
make
you've given us a lot to think about
i i think i've done quite enough
speaking to you today unless you need
more
oh
yes we do we i will i will uh i'll be
here all day oh okay uh well we'll we'll
uh toward the end i was gonna uh
try to take up not all of them just get
a an overall view of the
of the pfas bills maybe we now that
you're
yeah you're here
uh you
know i would uh i don't want to see you
go and i have to come back i'm i'm happy
to take a walk and come back at any
moment mr chair
but
whatever it would
when we want to just go fast through the
pfas bills
and i think
we'll then uh
all right we
what
we have the uh
do you have you gotten
well do you have a copy uh
of all of the people of the pfast builds
yes sir i do okay uh by the way anybody
everybody have their copy of this uh
yeah if you do you want it i made it i
made some additional copies this these
are all of the the hell the builds that
we are retaining
yeah it's
by our committee uh
committee researcher and she did a
fantastic job
it's better than having the bills
believe me in front of you
uh
just
uh just to try uh do you have a copy of
oh i have this online
okay all right we're just uh just going
down the
going down the just going down the list
the establishing a maximum containment
level for perfluorinated chemicals in
basically we're monitoring
let's see committee recommended interim
study to allow us to evaluate these bill
together with the new des standards and
return the body necessary legislation
to protect new hampshire's pristine
waters
the
this is awareness of dangers uh
establishing a maximum contaminant level
for perfluorinated chemicals
in surface water
we're
we're basically uh
just monitoring it
and with uh
uh
to see how uh
it
how des is doing
the uh
relative to that to this build the
contaminants
uh
you underst you you have that in front
of you
okay
yes sir uh yes sir any comment on this
des was opposed to this bill for a
variety of reasons and really this comes
down to the fact that this is a highly
changing environment um and as people
may have seen last week there was a new
notification from epa they're starting
to look at some health guidance and what
we heard from that the important take
home from that is that epa is working on
mcl's
uh that will help to inform the state
process so you know i think that this is
one of these where
by the time we get around to hearing
what epa comes up with having it go
through the public process that they're
going to go through because they're
going to go through a public you know
public comment and all of that vetting
process
we're going to be a year from now really
before we hear what epa is really coming
up with so this is a bill that that i
think would be
you know i think in september of 2023
that may be ripe again for some new
legislation but at this point you know
we've developed some of the most highly
protective uh policies in the in the
nation we're so far ahead of most of the
nation on this issue
that we feel like this is the the time
right now is to you know let the science
catch up and let the policy catch up
from the federal level to where we've
been because we've been so far out in
front and we'll have much better
thank you any uh other questions
that of post
thank you very much mr chair um i just
wanted to know what an mcl is so an mcl
is a maximum contaminant limit and it's
simply a number that if you get above
that it's
not good for people to drink
so you know the maximum contaminant
levels that have been established for
some of the pfas chemicals so for you
know p p p phoa and p foss you know we
developed those they're in the parts per
trillion range
um you know we have lots of other mcl's
about lots of other things from
nucleotides to you know halogens to all
kinds of different uh these mcl's for
okay
14 house bill 1440
relative to surface water quality
standards
go right ahead
your comments i testified on this bill
uh
back in looks like february uh we
addressed this one actually no was
january 25th
that we uh had that hearing
uh here in front of you and uh at that
point the department was opposed to the
bill
um interestingly since then
epa has now come out with some
additional draft
criteria that would apply for aquatic
life so you know one of the things that
we said when we developed our plan uh we
as you recall there was a bill that
required us to develop a plan by january
of 2020 to look at how we were going to
be regulating pfas compounds in surface
waters
as part of that plan one of the things
that we identified was a huge expense at
developing our own criteria because of
the amount of ex basically new science
that had to be developed epa is finally
developing that science there are some
draft numbers on the street
that will be out probably in a year or
so
in the meantime we are well on our way
to developing rules for uh water quality
standards that will go into effect
hopefully by next january we're about to
publish a draft of those rules
which will take the mcls
that the representative post asked about
it will put those into our surface water
standards where they apply for drinking
water sources
so the way that we apply that is
upstream 20 miles of of a drinking water
intake from a surface water so that's
that criteria that you're that goes into
the groundwater standard today that's
what mcl's deal with the groundwater
those numbers will be the same numbers
for surface waters for surface water
sources of drinking water but hopefully
by january or so so we're getting very
close to entering the formal rule making
process on that so this bill is
essentially
i i think we're already doing what it's
telling
us to do
and
uh and and this is such a hot topic that
you know we're going to be in front of
you
for a very long time uh on an annual
basis talking about this so i think that
that this rule this this law again is
going to be
overridden by by both action that des
has already taken as well as federal
okay future you
representative uh grassy
yes mr cheers would this bill
serve a purpose you know if we
introduced it in the fall
and you're saying it could be january
before we find out what we want to do
could this bill be a vehicle
to amend
in
january or february
to
allow you to enact some of the stuff
that's coming down from the federal
government that you want to put into law
thank you for the question
representative i i think that we're a
year away from really having all the
information that we want when i said
january that's going to be when we're
going to have rules published so so we
were we will already be down the road by
then so i don't know that there's
anything new that we're going to know
between now and the next session that's
going to necessary necessitate some
smith thank you mr chair and thank you
again mr dears um
when you say the rules uh will be
published in january is that mean that
will be when the public hearings begin
thank you for asking the question no we
intend to be having public hearings in
the fall
perfect thank you no i want to have the
rules finalized by january i'd like to
okay
remember in september we are going we
will be the time we will be
actually
disposing of the you know interim study
on these bills so september and october
so
this is just a cat this is just a
checkup
renaming the department of environmental
services the department of environmental
protection don't even bother to
don't don't even comment on that and
assigning the department oversight to
private drinking water wells
uh
i think it goes without saying that this
was something that um
that the department was not uh in favor
of uh particularly yeah certainly the
renaming would be extraordinarily
expensive yeah um and unclear as to what
the benefit would be um and also just
from a i will tell you living inside of
des
the services piece is really important
to us uh we take that very seriously at
des we intend to provide excellent
customer service and if we're not we
like to hear about it because we we
really do have that as part of our ethos
and in in terms of the the drinking
water piece um
we believe that we already have the
authority to do what you suggested oh
and look who's behind me thank goodness
saved by the bell
good morning everyone
mark sam lauren assistant commissioner
of new hampshire des
the commissioner asked me to come down
on this bill in particular
uh we testified
um before
we have uh we would be very
um strongly opposed to renaming the
department both for the
increase in cost and the
um
as ted was about starting to explain and
he's been in the department a lot longer
than i have um we really do think that
the department of environmental services
much more represents
the culture and
the approach we like to take in terms of
being customer service i'm not
the
seem to be more draconian um the the
other name and what's associated with
the protection you know where we're here
to provide services to the public and
help them accomplish their goals and
their projects while obviously keeping
our resources safe
so the commissioner asked me to come
down and make sure
we
supported ted in delivering that message
you have a question
of course all right of course uh thank
you mr chair um and thank you
assistant commissioner it's the first
time i've met you
um
i have uh
well there's two parts of this the first
one is i know that that there's been a
lot of concern for a long time that
every other
environmental agency in new england has
the word protection in it
that they don't see them their
their duty as to facilitate
development etc but i respect what
you're saying and i can certainly see
the logic of that
i'd like to address the second part of
it
i got very involved with some of you
guys over there at des
with the problem of arsenic
in drinking water
and i'm trying to get people in my
community to be testing and send those
test results into des
i believe the arsenic is
overlooked and very large problem
in this state
if des doesn't do it who will who will
make sure that we begin to address the
problem of arsenic and private drinking
water wells
so i'll i'll speak but this is also one
i'll ted add in anything um
you know we actually feel
um we already have the ability to
request permission to access folks
private property there's a process
um you know
when we testified the first time when
this bill was up um we talked to our
staff and staff has
you know
you know access has never been a a
problem in terms of determining uh
testing wells and so um and there's a
process in place that has always worked
for us so
um it's not that we don't
agree in terms of the intent we just
think this goes beyond what's needed and
our current process and what's in uh
statute um it works for us and um the
few times there are problems you know we
can work with the town and figure out
you know hacks but uh staff has said
very comfortable in terms of our
existing process and our ability to you
know as you know for the pvas we've done
more testing on private than you know
percentage-wise in almost any um
state in the country and we've been able
to do that very successfully working
with the homeowners and our existing
authorization ted junior you want to add
well
to that issue i think certainly you you
covered in terms of arsenic certainly
that's an issue and one of the things
that des did
uh two years ago
we uh launched a program that would get
point of
point of use treatment
for arsenic two people who have wells
for anyone who was either expecting a
child or or wanted to be expecting a
child
and those are the most vulnerable
populations for arsenic
the wastewater treatment plant or the
water treatment plants the the community
systems around the state uh recently you
know the mcl was recently lowered for
arsenic so so people are starting to
that's happening that that's getting
treated
wells and individual wells is certainly
a concern and it's one that the des
continues to have i don't think this
this this this particular bill
was the vehicle to deal with that uh but
they're certainly um you know
we have been encouraging people to get
their wells tested for arsenic we
encourage people to get their wells
tested for lots of things
um
and making i think this point of
treatment point of use treatment
available especially for vulnerable
populations
i i think is going to be the the
approach that is
that is is prudent at this point
you can't make someone test their well
because this is really about your
personal
your personal health
it's what you're drinking out of your
faucet
and so you know it's different when it's
a community system because you don't get
to control what's in that but when
you're in your own home
you know you you do and so i think that
this is one of those touchy places in
which
we would like to be helpful and if
there's thoughts around you know the
state on how we can be more helpful
especially to vulnerable populations
you know i think that that's something
that we would love to talk with people
about but at this point i don't know
that there's a legislative remedy for
you know for this issue of individual
well owners um and their desire to get
their water tested this bill wouldn't be
that this bill is really about
entering someone's house if there's
some other issue going on and i don't
think that was like that's going to
happen not
not and not in this state or at least
does this have a subcommittee no
this will not have a subject yeah i this
yeah
there's two different issues i think
i'm happy to follow up with you about
this the specific issue you're talking
about um i i don't think this bill would
um achieve your ultimate goal that
you're looking to achieve we
we have the ability right now to work
with homeowners and and test their wells
and if it's part of a larger testing and
um or if something's going on locally
and that process has always worked and
we've
uh you know our staff assured us we've
never had a problem um working with the
homeowner to to test and um we we don't
feel um this would uh benefit the
process in any way
okay maybe we can talk later
all right uh moving right along
uh
we'll uh
us house bill 1602 relative to
perfluoronated chemicals and drinking
water uh that was uh
uh that had to do with uh
representative grassy's uh
a similar bill we had uh
someone
came in and did speak to us about that
when was that uh
right a little bit a little because a
month or two ago
[Music]
right
yep
yeah and as there's there's no one here
to testify i don't think on that that i
think we're up to date on that then this
uh well i said he would be back
uh later on with additional information
if i'm not mistaken right but i think
it's information we may be getting
during the summer yep but
the thing is as well as this bill was
similar to the lead bill which we passed
yes as far as uh monitoring and
reporting out a number of things that
are in 1421 i think it was uh and uh
which is on the governor's desk
and uh so you know it may be something
that we want to take a look at as part
of
you know i would say if you if you're
planning on putting some of these um
these pfas bills together in a committee
that we just sort of slip this one in
there and and have it sitting there
whether we do anything with it or not
it uh i think would something that the
committee would at least be able to take
testimony from the state if they had any
if des have has any further stuff that
going on
uh house bill the last one i think uh on
pfast is
uh adding several perfluorinated
chemicals to the list
of per and
polyfluorinated floral alkyl substance
substances
with maximum contaminant level and
establishes cumulative total et cetera
et cetera
[Music]
you have a comment on that uh
thank you this was uh a bill that again
i think
we it's very similar to 1167
and we had some of the similar testimony
on that the des was opposed to that for
a number of reasons
mostly because
the the actual numbers that were being
proposed we do not think were supported
yet in the science
and so the challenge that we had there
was really that the scientific evidence
relative to pfba and pfbs
would essentially um
were not supported yet by the scientific
research that we had seen we also had
concerns about combining different kinds
of pfas into a combined number and the
reason for that is that they have
different effects different chemicals
have different effects on the human body
and so we didn't feel that we have not
felt and we have we've testified on this
any number of times that we do not feel
it is appropriate
at this point given what we know today
to come to combine them into a combined
number
uh and so this is this is again part of
the the sort of nuances of of pfas and
how they're being regulated around the
country but in our estimation this is
not yet an appropriate way to develop
these kinds of numbers uh in a combined
manner so those were the tests that's
testimony we gave um again we're gonna
see epa come out with a whole raft of
new science stuff that's coming out of
an academy of science and we'll know a
lot more about what this what some of
these chemicals are and what they're
doing um or at least what we know about
them uh over the next uh you know six to
nine months we'll have a much better
understanding at least of the newest
science
of the pass builds
uh you have a
question
uh
is there any more uh any
i don't wanna
this is
we are going to be this uh there are not
there's i will not be uh calling uh
any
uh
convening a
work session
on the these any of these pfas fills
they will go
they will be taken up at the executive
sessions that we will have
in uh september and october so
i'm not not forming any
subcommittee on
okay uh
let's get uh let's
house bill
establishing
yes you're excused i don't think there's
anything much more we can ask
the the ted talk has ended
um
thank you for
being here today yeah thank you all i
appreciate it thank you
so much
257 all right for sure
man remember this will be before us a
uh senator david waters district uh four
and um just a couple quick words on on
257 i really appreciate ted deer's
thorough explanation of what's happening
with the great bay
and really the extraordinary nature of
the agreement with the epa because they
are ready with a sledgehammer to come
down and cost us hundreds of millions of
dollars more
if we don't get the deal with the
nitrogen i wanted to pass around
the bill as introduced
and just point this out as some options
for you
the bill is introduced you'll see on
lines eight to ten
just applied to the
great bay communities those folks who
are under the ms4 mandate
so that was the original
bill
um senator guida who's particularly
interested in the lakes
and his you know legislation about
algebras and other things
suggested two things one was that
it'd be expanded to potentially include
other areas beyond
the great bay
and then secondly
uh you'll see in the amended bill
senator geider particularly thought we
ought to have cost estimates so that
town councils and city councils
would in town meetings would have a
thorough understanding
of if they set up a district what kinds
of expenses might be involved for the
taxpayers makes a lot of sense
it might be easiest for the committee in
the subcommittee to think about
separating out whether we just do the
great bay communities now because we are
under this epa mandate
and there are communities who are
forming stormwater utilities
and this would be useful to them to save
money for taxpayers right now
and that perhaps the issue of the lakes
is one that could be addressed in uh
in other legislation so that's all i
wanted to suggest mr chairman and thank
you
any questions
we'll be moving right along well let's
look let's go down the list uh
house house
bill
establishing a safety program for off
highway recreational
vehicles
and snowmobiles
uh
representative egan this uh this is your
bill
uh could you bring us up to date on it
uh and just uh
uh where you think where where uh if you
think you might wanna go
uh we're talking we're consideration
about uh
folding it in uh bringing it before
uh the
the uh
the
uh level house bill was at 1188
committee commission but uh
i haven't seen it approved yet uh signed
uh
do you where do you think where do you
think this ought to be thank you mr
chair yeah i am inclined to ask for the
commission if so then
created into law to take up this uh in
speaking with fish in game and the
insurance department and
other
trade associations involved in the bill
that would be the wisest place for it to
be
moved forward and
a lot of them have agreed that it would
actually be a top priority of that
commission
um so i think we'd be able to take a
good look at
um
as well the differences between the two
industries that are impacted ohrv versus
snowmobiles um so
while this bill was well intentioned
i think the commission would be able to
separate it out see what parts overlap
that are worthwhile that apply to both
ridership as well as be able to figure
out what are specific needed for for the
distinct ridership of each or uh
community i think so
my inclination is to do that i guess i
was hoping that i would learn today of
the commission's status so that would be
my one question
representative
representative post yes thank you um um
is there anything in this um
that addresses the fact that some
railways and things are not no longer
being indemnified
by their insurance companies for
ridership
no there's not that is that was an
important part that i think i wanted to
have as a discussion i did have a couple
uh initial discussions courtesy of the
um
the direct the director with the deputy
insurance commissioner regarding um then
they were going to check back with
the lead agency on behalf of the state
regarding
um two matters indemnification and um
as well as could
ridership
that
took the
safety exam and did see a fee could they
get a
discount on their insurance because they
took a safety test and therefore the fee
would become less complicated they'd
actually get a discount
you know and the fee would become moot
so that was one conversation and the
other one was about
where does
liability come into play based on
you know class six roads easements all
i think and and i'll defer to the
captain because he may he definitely
knows more than i do um
that there's still a gray area about and
i think if not a gray area that there is
confusion
with
landowners homeowners writers where and
where where i can't go and who's liable
and i think that would be an important
part of the commission is as well a
if not a law but also some communication
initiatives that i know both trade
associations um
for each respective ridership or hrv
snowmobile would be interested in making
what
where they can ride safely and it might
help them with some of the issues that
we do see where riders are going off the
trailer
uh
awry in easements so those two
issues were brought up in those
discussions with the
um like i said with direct with the
director from fish and game and the
representative smith thank you and
representative egan you had asked what
was the status of 1188 it has not yet
been signed into law
okay
i will
still
feel confident that it will and that
this bill should be an integral part of
that commission
i don't think we need i think really
what we the decision that has to be made
is do we need a subcommittee for this
and i don't think we do i don't think we
do and i'll just
i'll just look at the captain if is
there anything that i
did not
reflect or reflect inaccurately
thank you
yeah and so we're really the decision is
uh is
no no subcommittee
one of the um issues that was brought up
in a uh conversation earlier is that the
bill
puts lumps ohrvs and snowmobiles in the
same
category so in the interim study report
we probably should indicate that that's
something that should be separated out
we separated out snowmobile and ohrv
statutes a few years ago in legislation
so
this part should be in that category
also exactly and that's why i think the
commission will be able to look at the
overlap between the two industries and
the
and where there stands to be
separate
policy for them based on
you know
seasonality
um
the type of machine you know
you can't apply one law to everything
and that's
something i learned very well in in
crafting this
or attempting to craft this piece of
legislation
you mr chair uh if i could ask captain
eastman a question
uh i'm on equestrian and we received a
request from uh new hampshire i think
horse council that on the training for
education of the riders
that it include etiquette about what to
do when you
come across a horse and a horseman on
the trail
i don't know if you already do that so
could you comment do you already have
etiquette in your training for what
these snowmobiles and off track vehicles
should do if they approach a horse
thank you for the question i
i've just recently reviewed our online
uh
course as far as and there is certainly
an etiquette portion in there um the
whole course
doesn't speak specifically it speaks
specifically to
multi-use trails i mean obviously any
any trail out there um whether it's
snowmobile or ohrv is subject to
um you know uh
like dog
you know certainly horses and and
hikers and and um you know dog teams
sled teams uh you know in the wintertime
so there is some of that etiquette um
and of course etiquette as far as
stewardship for landowners and and you
know public lands and things of that
nature
um captain eastman might i direct the
horse council person to speak to you
directly because i asked them if they
had any other
comments i don't trail ride i show so
i'm not used to what happens when you
but i do see cars uh causing my horse to
have a problem if i'm at a show and they
backfire or whatever so if i can i'll
direct them to talk to you maybe get
some details into you that might help
the training
most certainly it will take any anything
[Music]
house bill 1620 uh which is identifying
part of the merrimack river as a
protected river there's no is there
anyone here to speak to that
if not we'll just
if not we'll just go on it's uh
oh
you can it's i mean it's just we we just
held it there in case somebody
uh comes in and says
we got a lot of stuff here that we can
you know that we're
we're ready to go or that kind of thing
thank you mr chair for uh
inviting me back up um i i think that uh
we have heard that certainly uh folks
are interested uh at some point uh of
talking about bringing in the the uh
this middle section the missing section
the gap
uh of the uh of the merrimack into the
rakes lakes i almost said it rakes and
livers uh the lakes and rivers programs
um
that the um
but again i think that what we heard in
testimony and what we've heard i think
from the local folks is that they're
interested in going through the process
as it's currently set up in statute
uh and so you know i think that if if
this committee were to take up some
portion of this bill it would be the
other part of the bill
which which we recommended that if you
were going to do something with this
is that the addition of the
of that middle section should happen
through current statute but there was
this little piece that sits in law
that's been in there for 30 years
relative to penichak water works and
the you know the ability to withdraw
water at certain amounts
des we are concerned
that given the situation
as we all know about pfas in the
southern part of the state
and the new investments that the
communities are making
in the southern new hampshire water
connection systems and i think you're
all well aware of of the new systems
that are going in through salem uh down
in windham uh that are coming you know
bringing water in
that there may be a need
to address that particular piece now
whether or not that should be a
standalone piece of legislation that
could be introduced in september and
take it up next year or if that's
something that you want to talk about
next next fall you know that that really
truly is up to up to the chair and and
the committee
but it's something that probably ought
to get addressed at some point
it's not it's not critical today it's
not critical this year
but certainly future planning um this is
an issue that that that probably should
be addressed
and i have tracy sales who's our
lakes and rivers uh manager and um if
any uh any questions on that
okay uh
again i will i don't think we're gonna
have a subcommittee on this
i don't believe but it would be
discussed obviously at our uh
when we exact this
thank you and thank you and um
miss sales and mr dears um we received
we were given a letter after the public
hearing uh that commissioner scott
wrote to
mayor craig and the board of aldermen in
manchester
uh telling them about this bill and
asking for their responses and i
wondered if you knew what had come out
of that if anything
thank you for the question uh we we have
not received to my knowledge we have not
received a formal response in any manner
from either any of the three communities
who received that letter so
anecdotally
um uh assistant commissioner sanborn did
hear
you know that there was some discussion
going on and that people were you know
it sounded like the boards were nobody
was you know ruffled that much about it
but i think that we had really wanted
something a little bit more than that
um and and we did not get that
thank you
[Music]
is it captain emeritus or captain
or did they give you a promotion on the
way out like
are you are you know you're now a
colonel major
retired
[Laughter]
yeah uh
if you
well i think it's just allowing
everybody to back to
uh or
what this is what you hear about is uh
we uh in the discussion originally on
this bill
uh it was we found that
you were
the
coast guard was concerned with the fees
uh and uh and we thought maybe this is a
good bill maybe use it as a vehicle to
see what we can't move the ball along
thank you mr chair that is a a an
accurate summary of of what we came
before you with
uh at the time of
representative trottie's bill to look at
registration fees
i've given you a one-page handout
as sort of an educational tool it
references some attachments but i'm not
going to burden you with the attachments
today
they're just essentially copies of
statute
that being said
our concern after a coast guard desk
audit
which happens every couple of years
as a result of new hampshire or the
marine patrol specifically receiving
federal monies to help with recreational
boating safety it's called the
recreational boating safety grant but
it's not anything we apply for it's
simply new hampshire's share that is
shared with
56 states and territories uh in our
country
with
fish and wildlife agencies and agencies
responsible for recreational boating
safety
um the feds disperse that money uh that
comes from uh taxes assessed on fishing
gear hunting gear
we have to be compliant however with
certain things in order to be eligible
for those funds
and one of the items that we need to be
compliant with is the federal bound
numbering system the federal
registration system for recreational
votes and as i pointed out to you as a
result of that audit it was determined
that
the state was in violation of
federal code
when we collected fees unrelated to the
boat registration itself
and you'll see in my handout
categories of what a person pays when
they register their boat in our state
the top paragraph in 270e is a flat rate
fee depending upon the length of your
boat
and by statute
those revenues come to the marine patrol
in the middle page and i put a red flag
next to it
is a series of additional fees that are
collected at the time of the boat
registration that go to outside agencies
that's what is in violation of
federal code
um that that we are hoping we can come
before you and and and receive some
legislative relief
on on
the collection of those fees while at
the same time we recognize how important
those fees are to the agencies that
receive them
i think it's pretty self-explanatory
where they go
and when you when you look at those
numbers
times 100 000 votes give or take
depending upon the year
um those those revenues are important to
those agencies
then in addition
at the bottom are the
boat fees
that are also in a separate statute
uh that are assessed uh by mill rate
depending upon the length of your boat
the type of your boat whether it's a
cabin cruiser or a sailboat
and how many engines it's equipped with
uh the interesting thing is is the
history of those mill rates go back so
far that they don't even account for the
fact that we now have boats that have
three four and five outboard engines off
the back of them
so um
we thought that perhaps it was time to
bring this
to a head instead of kicking the ball
down the field continuously look at some
of these issues
in the early 90s marine patrol was a
general funded agency
and
being seasonal in nature
we were scraping the bottom of the
barrel every year to provide the
services that we had come to be expected
by the voting public
with the help of the new hampshire
marine trades association new hampshire
lakes and an overall awareness by the
legislature that that more money needed
to go to boating safety in our state
they created the navigation safety fund
which was a dedicated revolving fund
where marine patrol would receive the
revenues of voting registrations
prior to that the passage of that bill
the towns that would register boats
and the marinas within those towns that
would register boats
that was in the early 90s
unfortunately an unintended consequence
of that as we are now in 2022
it has created a competition for those
funds between the state
and the towns that are registering boats
and so
where there has been no increase since
that time in these rates
uh that competition is now catching up
with us
and while
the towns do great things with those
revenues
um
it's time before it gets too late to
look at this overall registration system
and you'll see at the bottom of the
paragraph the statute where it says
any money that is collected by the town
or a boat agent
that being a marina within that town
stay with the town
i've brought jeff oberdenk here today
from the dmv who can speak to where
those revenues go and how they how
they're split up between the state and
the town
and and the overall issue that
this system creates with us being able
to provide an online renewal service
which the public is screaming for uh
especially during covert and even the
town clerks some want to be involved
some don't and i'll let jeff expand on
that but we are here today in hopes that
that we can move forward uh with some
sort of legislative relief
primarily to address um
the the issue with the uh the federal
government uh and the eligibility for
those funds we are currently out of
compliance
and those dollars are in jeopardy
happy to answer any questions before i
turn it over to jeff
thank you mr chair and thank you captain
dunleavy
um
so at the top of the page we have the
registration fees which
top off at ninety two
and then at the
uh in section the third little section
it says boat fees and then c attachment
two for tables
uh and they go up to seventeen hundred
sixty one dollars per boat
so i don't
so
there are other fees for boats besides
the registration
yes it's basically the same thing it's
one's a flat rate
that you see at the top and the bottom
is a mill rate
it's like
it's based on the value of your vessel
and it it declines over five years
um
so are we using that now we are the
issue ma'am is that
if i is the bone owner
register with the town
or in the case of a large marina that
may winterize and house
four thousand boats they provide a
tremendous service to their customers
where they actually will summarize the
boat get it ready for memorial day and
register it for them
or i walk into a marina because i need
to buy some life jackets and i take
advantage of the fact that that they
also register boats at the marina
my
my check for my boat registration
and the mill rate portion of my
and
so when you look at the significant
difference in the amounts of the portion
of the fee you pay for a boat
registration
uh if it's being if that transaction is
being conducted
with
an agent other than a dmv substation
or marine patrol headquarters those
and and for years that wasn't an issue
but over time it is caught up
because more and more people are looking
for
um
that ease if you will of this
transaction
and because of that competition for
those funds again
an unintended consequence
um
to go
how do you do how do you spread those
funds out if you go to an online
system and i'll let jeff speak more to
good morning everybody um as mr dunlop
you said my name is jeff obertank i've
been with the division of motor vehicles
for about uh 22 years now
20 years on the driver licensing side in
the last two on the registration side
and uh one of the reasons to the move to
the registration side was to seek out
efficiencies and better ways to do
business in a timely manner and
and be more customer service friendly
interesting to me when i started this
was that the registration process we
know for everything we have has to be
done in the town you live in
that's where boats are different
boat registrations can happen anywhere
and depending on where you register the
boat
as tim said that's where the money stays
uh and so as an example uh when i
started um i got to know the
town clerks association which we have
the president of the town clerks
association here today and one of their
asks of us the dmv
was how do we get boats online so
great
i got online driver license renewal
online ticket pay i helped get a lot of
those things over the finish line on the
driver's side
tim quickly jumped in and said time out
before you rush to get boats online um
you're going to take away more of our
revenue and up to 50 of the marine
patrol budget comes from registrations
so as an example i just want to run
through a couple of numbers here today
and in 2018
um
agents for the state which would be boat
marinas or
town clerks took in about 3.4 million
dollars in boat registration revenue and
the department of safety took in about
2.4 million dollars in revenue um
as cobit hit and people were looking for
that convenience and they were looking
to do
one-stop shopping
i'll fast forward to
year
the towns took in 4.4 million dollars in
revenue and the state took in 1.7
so as you can see as people seek out
those efficiencies and they seek out to
be able to do that one-stop shopping
model
we're taking away a big chunk of marine
patrol's revenue
and and from my standpoint
the the process of tying
the registration fees to funding marine
patrol works out perfectly because here
we're in a year where
last year we registered 107 000 boats
which pre-covet is about 15 000 more
than we've ever done in history right
everybody wanted to get outside
boating was the thing to do where you
could be with your family and those
types of things so the numbers shot up
well fifteen thousand more boats means
that we need more patrol we need more
education we need more officers on the
water if you have a down year and you're
only registering 80 000 votes or so
then you don't need as much money so
tying it to the registration works in
that regard historically
but where the money goes depending on
who registers it is the thing that we
need to fix
and again we do have the town clerks
association president here as well
we understand moving the the model
online they very much want to provide
that service for their citizens they
want to reduce their footprint as well
people don't have to come into the
office you can register your car online
why can't you register a boat online
we've hesitated because of this and
we're hoping that we can hook on
to the coast guard fixes and the things
that they need
to moving towards a better funding
stream
seeing where things go
um so that we can get the online model
that the citizens are asking for and and
with that i'll um i'll take any
questions
thank you for taking my question um you
said that town clerks are here
have you had discussions with the town
clerk about
perhaps agreeing on a split percentage
instead of they keep their money and you
keep your money if you went online and
you just put it all in a pool i'm just
example you give 60 the towns get 40 no
matter where
the fees come from
we have that's uh and that has to be
something we pursue through legislation
um currently right now as you see from
what mr dunleavy gave to you it's it's
pretty clear what we can take in and
where the money goes based on the two
statutes
and we're kind of the thought process
says we're going to lift the hood and
fix those coast guard elements then
let's find a way to get the revenue
um this is for uh captain dunn olivia
follow up if if my math is correct
the amount of money that goes to the
other state agencies on a hundred
thousand boats is like a million seven
hundred
and and i'm wondering do you have an
idea of a suggestion how would we make
up for those
agencies the million seven hundred
dollars
that's a tremendous question
representative thank you we are we are
exploring uh we are not the only state
that is wrestling with this issue with
the federal government at this time we
are exploring an avenue in which we can
still preserve
those revenues for those outside
agencies and meet uh the requirements of
federal statute um
and and so we are working with the coast
guard on that matter right now
um
but but what they're using for the
litmus test
is that if a person walks in to register
their boat
and all they want to do is pay
what it costs them to be able to get a
decal to go out fishing that afternoon
that's what the federal government wants
to see
they don't want to have
something attached to that transaction
that has anything to do
with anything but that boat registration
so
exploring one lump tax and then behind
the scenes dispersing it
they've said you can't do it it's still
going to be in statute saying that's
where those revenues go
so we're working with them on a solution
some states have achieved that and and
that's where we would be seeking
legislative relief and the changes to
accommodate those revenues to those
agencies
one other quick point i'll point out
that
it has become known by the towns that
here's an availability for for funds for
simply providing a service and i and i'm
not
the competition for these funds is not
something that marine patrol
um
we're against the competition but we're
not against the fact that the towns are
receiving these revenues they use it in
tremendous ways on their waterfront
whether they're supporting and repairing
and providing town docks or whether
they're uh helping
add additional funds to uh the fight of
aquatic invasive species and their
section of their lakes
there are a variety of ways that that
these revenues are being used by the
towns and given back to the boater who
is shouldering this
revenue
fact is there are some towns that don't
have a single acre of public waters
within their boundaries that are
receiving revenues from
about registration
and i think it was the intent of the
legislature in the early 90s
for that user pays user benefits system
thank you mr i actually have two
questions one for the chair and then one
for our guests um the question for the
chair do we know who authored this
legislation because i don't have it
in
because i obviously uh as soon as you
said online registration i looked over
at captain eastman and smiled because
that was a previous bill that actually
this committee did pass and has gone to
the governor's desk for ohrv and
snowmobile so i'm very interested in
this to sort of make life for our
visitors or our state residents
um in the efforts of you know promoting
it was going to be
taxing votes by the by no rate
right it was just not worth
it it was using the mill rate that
replied to motor vehicles
and and that that's fine for some boats
but when you look at the value of the
average cost of a new boat now being
maybe 30 to 40 for an automobile you're
looking 100 to 150 for boat so for those
that class of boats it would have been a
tremendous tremendous expense
that just
right while not a good bill it was the
it actually unearthed a good problem to
try and solve without beer
so my question then for our either one
of you are there states that are doing
this well or have that you both we
referenced you know that have done this
well or or have achieved
um
looking at this that
we as legislators could look at and try
and glean
some insight from
certainly the state of connecticut is
just i'm told by the coast guard uh a a
pretty good model to follow and so i
well i haven't laid eyes on that model
yet uh i do have a calling today
thank you very much thank you for your
time
american enslavement
uh
this there will be a subcommittee on
this
thank you again mr chairman senator
david waters district four and i
appreciate working with the opportunity
to work with the
subcommittee but for the full committee
i just wanted to note a couple of things
briefly um
if you've had a chance to familiarize
herself with the underlying
existing statute on burying grounds
you have seen that we already have a
process whereby municipalities or others
wishing to
do something about these bearing grounds
have to
contact the descendant community and if
they cannot be identified do a posting
in the newspaper and work with town
officials and as you recall this bill
adds
the
constitution
with um a representative organization of
the descendant community so um based on
you're hearing i just want to mention
two two possible things um
on line
eight and nine
concerned about naming the black
heritage trail of new hampshire
and it occurred to me that we could just
do here what we do for native american
graves
and let the historical resources
designate
the representative community so it could
say
or an organization
representing representative of
the african-american descent community
as designated by the new hampshire
division of historical resources um and
as i said that's what they do with
native american
graves and they could certainly
figure out who's best for municipality
to consult with there
um secondly uh
if you turn to the second page of the
bill
the section at the bottom
lines
33-36 about examining collections for
remains of
african-americans from the period of
enslavement
that i think that perhaps it makes sense
just to keep it to that
and on line 33 strike any other and any
other remains of people of african
descent born after the period of
american slavery
and similarly on lines 35 36
and i recommend this because i think it
simplifies it and also because i've
become aware that
there is international treaty language
that covers um
materials that may have been removed
from
african
countries whether bones you know remains
or grave goods and the united states is
a signatory to that treaty they have
meetings regularly and determine such
things as repatriation of of grave items
and otherwise so there's no point in our
we don't need to do that in state
statute
so this would be just be that if you
have human remains in
state you know medical collections or in
historical societies and i mentioned and
or universities i mentioned before i do
know of at least one case of this and i
suspect there are more that then this
will be an opportunity to uh
do the right thing by those human
remains thank you mr chairman and i look
forward to working with the subcommittee
any questions or comments from members
of the
committee
thank you mr chair thank you senator um
i don't have the bill in front of me
could you perhaps cross out on us draft
what you want and send it to us
or what you're suggesting i'll be glad
to do that thank you i just realized i
was going to hand you this i said you're
not going to be able to read my writing
[Laughter]
i did
send everyone a
uh
i did
make copies of this article lawmakers
slam brakes on protecting the black
grave sites i don't know if uh if
everybody was able to i wasn't able to
you got a copy okay anyone
here's
you got one okay
all right
uh
it's
you know interesting readings
take a you know jeeps last night
spent some time just you know going over
to bill the bill actually didn't even go
over all of it just uh
but i was just
we needed we do need a
subcommittee on this simply because we
need
to hear from
the people who are affected and those
who are
doing the uh
the job of
keeping up the cemeteries and the grave
sites and that we never heard from them
there was no testimony of that so we
need
we need that testimony uh
and we need to so we can judge the
impact that
this bill might have on him uh and
how many graves are we talking about
we don't know
is there any data on that uh
thank you mr chairman a couple of things
i i the division of historical resources
regretted they hadn't been able to send
someone to the original hearing because
they're the one of the bodies that that
deals with this um as as well as some
local cemetery officials but again
bearing grounds are in this funny
category because they're not town
cemeteries um they are owned by the
descendants of the community
as far as how many there are
i don't think
we'll hit a hundred burial sites
for african americans from the period of
enslavement
um
that are actually burial sites rather
than just single graves
yes
yeah i mean there are there are many
many and we're being rediscovered
um you know yearly
and if i don't i can't give an exact
figure but i will say that there were
there were thousands of people
enslaved in new hampshire during the
period of enslavement
so there are many there are thousands of
burials whether or not they have been
identified or they're in
distinct burial grounds um but this is a
lot of the kind of ongoing work of
black history organizations and local
cemetery buffs too
and are you looking
do you expect that there there should be
a different set of statutes or laws
concerning
established graveyards
versus discoveries of uh
of burial grounds that
either were
lost to history or we didn't even know
existed
because
i would assume that the
the
well the whole the whole techniques that
necessary to
to do what you have to do is uh
is
is radically different
well thanks for your question mr
chairman so if you look in um statute
you'll see that we have kind of two
separate areas one is cemeteries
which are public
publicly or religious organization owned
and then there are burying grounds which
are the property essentially of the
people buried there and their
descendants
and they have a separate statutory
language because the town does not own
them unless they have voted to take
responsibility for them and most towns
won't do that because then they'll have
to fence them and pay for upkeep and and
so on
there are many african-americans from
the period of enslavement who are buried
in existing cemeteries so up in
canterbury here in concord you know
portsmouth throughout
the state
there are people now they may be buried
down in a swampy area or sometimes
they're buried just outside the wall but
those folks are
essentially taken care of by the by the
town and so this bill
um does not particularly apply to them
i would think that
if a community
in its cemetery was going to do
improvements or wanted to do a you know
particular commemoration or a marking or
replace the stone
or an african american who or s who may
never have had a gravestone um then that
they would certainly want to consult
with the communities but this gets this
gets at this
it's a it's an interesting section of
wall bearing bearing ground law because
the property you know who owns the
property is just
it's it's uh you know we have so many of
these um bearing grounds in new
hampshire
uh and so that's why this this addresses
that because that frankly is where most
african-american spirit of enslavement
are buried because um townspeople did
not want them
in the public cemetery or they'd be
buried out on the farm
or behind the house where they were
enslaved
you know a funny example for example is
in amherst where there's several
african-americans who were enslaved
buried
and it's a it's odd it was was that were
they buried in what was then part of the
cemetery or not
and then when they built a new beating
house in the 1800s they built it on top
of part of those graves so
you know there's just a lot of each one
has its own circumstances and um you
know i think that because there are
people now who have experience in
working with these uh bearing grounds in
new hampshire that they
um are happy to provide
some
expertise and and there are lots of
reasons why they should if somebody's
doing work in an african bearing ground
they may not recognize
that pieces of shell broken pottery or
even
salt sprinkled on top of the
grave our african practices and they
just think they may be trash
um so anyways it's just a
scenario that uh
in in statute we could um say hey let's
let's include these organizations who
kind of know how to respectfully treat
the remains of these
oh
uh i i can answer a couple ways um
you know if you're doing some work to
improve a bearing ground um that often
then there'd be an agreement over how to
do that and that's actually required an
existing statute
we already have that that if you're
going to do some work at a bearing
ground you have to get
approval from the town
you have a right to do it
under statute but you have you have to
go through a process and this would also
do that
as i said in my opening comments that
it would be you know maybe better if you
don't want to just name one organization
to let the
um historical resources as it does with
does with native american graves fine
and appropriate
representatives of the descendant
community depending on location tribal
affiliation and so on to do that
um
now the black cardistry of new hampshire
has undertaken and has substantial
funding for placement of
markers and monuments to commemorate
african americans in our state they just
did one over in warner
and i'm trying to remember the other
town um
and there are others that are you know
that are underway we have a
lot of trail markers in
portsmouth but now it's going statewide
and so when those are placed um
they uh have
a
bronze plaque that is on a granite
boulder
that has the information about the
individual
and the black heritage trail
has a refuge fiduciary responsibility
for the maintenance repair
or
whatever is needed on that on that so
a little clarification um so
they where do they get their funds
uh well um there are there are grants uh
they've received substantial grants from
national organizations and state
organizations you go to their website
and see their finances they also
raise hundreds of thousands of dollars a
year for i mean if you participated in a
juneteenth program over the last weekend
over saw one that was all black heritage
trail
sponsored and then july 1st around the
state including concord they're going to
be readings of frederick douglass's
4th of july address so anyways
there's a lot of visibility for their
programs but they have
uh
funding that they they raise they're a
non-profit and they raise money okay
a final question so uh
to
get a lock on it
would would this involve in any way
funds
state funds going to the black heritage
trail or
it would be
entirely a private
thing in terms of the fiduciary
responsibility would be an entirely
private thing
yeah thank you yeah and just to note any
improvement that is done in a burying
ground now
right now does not bear any any fetish
financial responsibility from the
municipality because the municipality
doesn't own it great that's very helpful
thanks
any other questions
much appreciated mr chairman and and uh
sorry the article mr chairman i prefer
uh
that
is it except i do have to
if we have what we say
one subcommittee on
uh
and
257.
another
the
navigation safety fund
now
did uh there's i know i know we were
short quite a few people
here
people want to call me and
send me an email want to be on which
i will be at all of them i will be on
you should probably leave me a lot
beyond one i'll be on some simply
because i might not get enough people
so
when are we allowed to come back to work
uh in uh i think it's the last week in
august
yeah i think i know september i thought
it might have been
it might have been the last week in
august
i thought it was the last few days in
i'll check in the front office
i'll i'll send something out on that
maybe that
and people just uh
and then if i looks like i can't i don't
huh
you're available
okay but uh and and i will i will
uh most september we're going to be
probably doing the most of the work in
september and in october is when we'll
going to that's going to the
uh eleven eight of
1188.
yeah
yeah there's going to be that commission
yeah we may
we may find that we may if that doesn't
get passed and that gets vetoed well
then
we can revisit correct if it doesn't
revisit everything we did today
was strictly to get our bearings
to know where we stand
uh
the
the pfast stuff
we went over i mean we're basically
you know pfast is a very
uh
and so we don't want we
but it's also uh we feel that
the edes seems to be on top of it
and
looks
so we'll just carry these along
uh just to uh
just just to show them the respect that
it deserve that they deserve
uh
oh well
all right uh but uh just
yeah maybe i won't i won't uh
i won't put any pressure on anybody but
i i will be
calling around if i don't hear from
people if i don't have enough
i've usually want at least five people
uh but
yes
um
i was very discouraged
that
i cannot i cannot predict what i don't
know how we can get a sense of
will serve on the subcommittee but you
understand why i would consider it to be
um they are revamping that too
like that
so
that doesn't necessarily what
just because uh you know what what
becomes a law is something different
for inst for instance
there may be an issue and we may not
like
we may say yes there is an issue
but the solution you bring for that to
that for that issue
so that's
that's called politic
i mean people
we we do have
you know
what we like is not necessarily what is
that
no the what where
no uh
the
they could they could make suggest
suggestions
for what to do and i think they are
making suggestions for what they do we
may say we agree that there you we may
say that there we agree there is an
issue
the solution you give us
because it's going to be very difficult
to fix something if we don't know
what the members of the committee
like we brought up
so that well that's nonsense
so how do you
come up with a solution if you don't
sounded pretty reasonable and clarifying
and you know i mean i really would like
to see but
figure out okay so what exactly is a law
saying now how can we make it stronger
without
making it more clear
so
how can we protect
the lakes
and the rivers and the bay
from
septic systems that aren't working
and we know this building works so what
if parts of it can use and what can we
that it could do some way to put
maybe even another
water going into a river
they thought it was one particular house
they ended up cutting their septic
systems
destroying their subject system because
they didn't have the plans to
to pay for that
engineer system
and it turned out to be another
homeowner upstream so i mean you're
putting a lot of people in bad positions
with
having this super expensive person that
has to come in so maybe that's
are you talking about
so
well
they're having to
i can jump in on that i don't think i
don't think the statue gives the
authority to wave it what they're waving
is home inspections because they do
reels they're waving home inspection
but i tell my clients that if there's a
shoreline protection statute that says
you have to have this report
go get the report now it doesn't say
what you have to do once you get the
report it doesn't say if the report says
the system's gonna fail you have to
upgrade but you you just get the report
and you read it and it's signed and it
gets filed with the board of health the
question i always brought up and even
listening to mr dears is
you know i practice folk in new
hampshire and massachusetts i just keep
hearing more things that lead me to
think it'll be a
title five nick paul in
massachusetts septic system requirement
i mean
i'm not
totally in favor of title five what
happens in mass is
every system
before you can sell a house whether
you're shoreline or not has to be
inspected
the inspection is about a 10-page report
signed by a licensed inspector not a
installer but an inspector
that goes to the board of health that
gets passed on to the homeowner and if
that inspector says it fails
yeah the homeowner has to upgrade it or
the new owner has to upgrade it you have
two years to upgrade it so what they've
been doing in years in massachusetts is
it's a spot thing if they have a problem
here it gets found and somebody's got to
fix it or you got to tie into the septic
system
and they were hoping and i don't have
any test results for you
but the plan was
with that put in place
they're correcting all failed systems
and we'll make them upgrade
there's not there's some money from the
state for credits for upgrading your
system but i heard
mr dears talk about other funds and
credits
but i think the whole discussion is
coming to
that do we really want something like
that in new hampshire that's what i look
at
if this
opportunity is not take
that accepting systems will continue
to throw these plates because people
don't want to
this is job for the
subcommittee
you know we're gonna we can be here till
next week arguing over the exact same
well do it on your own time
i mean i mean i got to you know
but
chuck you uh yeah mr chairman i'd be
happy to serve on this in fact i'd like
to serve on this committee because i
both experience as being a planner in a
short in a lakeshore community and also
doing a lot of research on um
private septic systems or innovative
septic systems for community for for
private communities and and public
communities as well and i think that if
you've got these two bills that we're
looking at and into one uh that ted
spoke on both of them today i think
there's a lot of experience that i can
bring to the table as well and in
discussions on these things and i being
certainly being sympathetic to
what judith's argument is is that you
know working in the in a lakeshore
community i have seen all kinds of
problems with failed septic systems
and uh it's certainly something that
does need to be done with because we're
actually paying a lot of money in state
funds
to treat the the problem
uh you know the effect that these fail
systems have i mean we're spending tons
of money for dealing with nitrogen in in
lake winnipesaukee and other lakes in
our state
and
much of it is due to failed septic
systems
and it's it's you know it's not just
water on the waterfront but within a
certain
distance from the lake you know i've
seen septic systems that are quite a
ways from lake that are that we're
basically leaking right into the the
lake and nobody's inspecting these
things and nobody's requiring that
they'd be done and we need to we need to
have something that is going to take a
look at these and how we do them i'm not
saying you know as as bob you know we
may not want to do the whole state but
we want to do something that's within a
but i think uh we're over we're riding
we're running over and
i think i think we're just petering out
but
uh
are we done
thank you
we're adjourned
let me know if you want who wants to be
on what committee you know
okay
directly